Damn!
Bleacher Report is innovative because we get to talk about sports
like the fans that we are
We're not inserting ourselves into the conversation,
we are the conversation
We are the sauce,
we're swagu. All day
At B/R, we come up with an idea, we brainstorm,
and then within a couple of hours
it’s across all of B/R’s platforms
It really comes down to us just figuring out what is
the best possible journey for the user to really
drive the conversation around those moments that matter
Anything that we think about that can resonate with our audience
that has ties to pop culture, sports, entertainment, anything
that our audience and we think is cool
and we can create, we will
You can walk
You wanna see what my life is?
B/R tells stories that stick to your bones
The kind of stuff you want to share in your group chat
or pass your cellphone to your friend,
and be like "yo did you see this?"
B/R came to us and we pitched them on Game of Zones,
which is a mashup of "Game of Thrones" and the NBA
And Bleacher Report said, “Great” and soon
it was all over the internet
It's game time!
It allowed us to really push the way that we
and everyone else are talking about sports,
through cartoons, and through humor and through
a different form of storytelling
There are no rules now!
So I started an Instagram account called House of Highlights
and after a few months, I was gaining some attention
and B/R recognized that
They thought what I was doing was unique and different
They brought me in
They believed in me. They got out of the way,
and they said “hey Omar we want you to be yourself"
And that really helped bring House of Highlights
to that next level
What are you doing?
At B/R, we own the moments
and our audience recognizes that
When you're sitting with your group of friends,
and somebody asks you, “Did you see that game last night?”
Somebody is going to say, “Did you see what Bleacher Report did?”
That’s the thing that gets people talking,
that’s the thing people really want to see,
that’s the difference between us
and everybody else